you guys might also do a Christmas carol
yet with we are definitely doing that I
mean that is written it's going to be
3-1 hours and it's largely done finished
in terms of the script we're planning to
shoot this year and hopefully get it on
the screen for Christmas so is it so
it's is this like a BBC thing whose it's
BBC plus an American element which has
not been announced yet I understand and
so what role is Tom playing in this not
gonna reveal say no again don't want to
get better but he's going to be pivotal
in the whole thing got it is it that's
not a clue have you thought about other
casting and stuff yeah yeah I mean we're
out to cut the people I mean what I'm
trying to do and what I'm planning to do
is adapt five Dickens no I mean
Christmas carols not really a novel but
adapt Christmas Carol plus four novels
and do it over a period of let's say six
or seven years and have a repertory of
actors and I think we'll get the best
actors hopefully in the world to to take
part because the Dickens characters are
so great and just do like Copperfield
and Oliver Twist and great expectations
and do them in in a modern way I mean
that not really in a taboo way but it's
sort of like that and well the thing
about taboo is it's real ready it is
like you're stepping back in time in
terms of the dirt yeah the mud yeah it's
like you were there so is that what you
kind of the element you want to add -
yes I mean the idea is that when Dickens
was writing I mean he would have been a
TV returning series writer I think
because that's how he worked and he when
he wrote his novels he did it in
installments and release them in
magazines so that people were that there
were cliffhangers and people were
waiting for the next episode and as far
as he could according to the sort of
fashions at the time he did deal with
the darker side of London and poverty
and you know things that were really
going on
he couldn't really go into the detail in
the way that we can now so what I'm
trying to do is things that are past
possibly implied in Dickens we can
actually Express I like this it will be
correct I think it's really good I mean
I think if we if we can buy each novel
eight hours of good television with
really good actors it'll be something
that you can at the end of it you can
say look I did this then I got it so
it's basically each year so this year
would be Christmas Carol what what do
you have an order or not set in stone
are quite fancy doing David Copperfield
mix it's so interactive would yet but
Tom would be in each one I think so yeah
of course what am i you know
you